now know that next week's strikes will
go ahead
what is the impact going to be
i think it's a huge mistake um
unfortunately uh the unions mick lynch
the rmt have been gunning for this
strike throughout um they back in april
they called the strike on the false
pretence with their members uh of taking
themselves off the pay freeze which of
course the whole of the public services
had uh for the past couple of years that
pay freeze was coming to an end anyway
the strikes are completely unnecessary
it's going to inconvenience millions of
people students doing their gcses and a
levels 17 different public exams in fact
people trying to get hospitals to try to
get to operations perhaps that have been
postponed during coronavirus it is
disastrous uh and it's no way um to
behave on the railway there's no
advantage uh to this i know that nick
lynch says he's quote nostalgic for
union power but this is no way to behave
uh you say there that you know they were
wrongly saying that there's going to be
a pay freeze but at the same time do you
not have any sympathy for workers who
are being hit by a massive cost of
living crisis um if you look at the
reports my understanding from these
reports seems to be that the pay offer
is around 2.5 percent inflation is
projected to hit 11 this year
people wages are not going to keep up
are they i'm very i'm very concerned for
everybody's
incomes and people who won't be able to
get to work as well next week but let me
just put this in context the railway has
had 16 billion pounds that's 600 pounds
per household in this country in
emergency funding to keep it going
throughout the coronavirus to make sure
that not a single employee of the
railways had to be furloughed or lost
their jobs so the taxpayer we've all
done our part
a train driver has paid on average
medium salary 59 000 pounds a nurse
one thousand pounds a care worker
because just to come back in mr chaps
because you are uh picking just the
train drivers here we know that these
strikes are not just train drivers is it
there's a lot more people much lower
salaries than that working on the uh
yeah on the railways aren't there to be
fair but the
is 44 000 pounds um so this is this is
not a badly paid industry i want people
to be paid more what we need is
modernization of some very antiquated
working practices which stretch back not
just to the 70s but in in some cases to
1919 which is
with regard to the failure to be able to
run trains on on sundays the world has
changed the hospitality market has come
back it's the one bit which has been
quite busy on the railways and we need
to change the modernize the the railways
so all we're asking for is modernization
in return uh for uh for pay uh and i
think that's a very reasonable thing to
ask for i think the public realize we
can't carry on putting the likes of 16
billion pounds in that's 160 000 pounds
of support per individual worker on the
railway uh over uh the last couple of
years we can't carry on doing that so
we've got to have a a reasonable
negotiation my big complaint is
yesterday afternoon
as these negotiations were ongoing uh
mick lynch and the rmt walked out and
went to a tuc rally instead they're
gunning for this strike i'm afraid and
it's going to inconvenience millions of
brits
um just uh quickly um you say you all
you want to see is modernization is that
just code for job cuts
well no i i'll give you a really good
example um
you know obviously no job is coming
hold on let me let me explain i'll give
you a really good example uh the safety
of the railway is incredibly important
obviously um at the moment it involves
people going out and walking along the
track too often which is dangerous and
i'm afraid i just recently read uh one
of the accident uh reports for somebody
who was killed on the track we i'm
afraid have have deaths every year
through this actually a train fitted
with sensors can take 70 000 images per
minute and drones can do the overhead
wires and it's far safer than sending
people on the tracks it requires
technology rather than people and so yes
we do need to reshape the workforce um
but
as i say what's happening at the moment
is the unions are stopping that
modernization they're not making the
railways any safer what does that mean
that means job cuts doesn't it let's
just talk in plain english
reshaping the world means some job cups
right we need to reshape the railway
around the needs of the railway today
does that mean job cuts
we've been asking for voluntary and
getting monetary redundancies so we
don't require
everybody in their current role but if i
can explain the way that things are set
up
sophie let me just let me just let me
finish this one point the way things are
set up in the railway at the moment is
like trying to conduct an orchestra but
you don't know whether the musicians
will uh to be able to sort of sit where
they need to sit whether they're going
to turn up whether they're going to
bring their instruments the
inflexibilities are built into the
contracts we need modernization on our
railways to be able to run them
efficiently more safely and in the
interest of passengers
so how many job cuts are you looking to
get
well there's already been 2 700
voluntary uh redundancies uh what we
know is that we
what i'm interested in is running an
efficient railway uh making sure we can
run the trains on time uh not uh running
railways based on old outdated practices
uh i don't know the exact uh i don't
know that is that number but what we're
looking to do is make sure the railway
runs for passengers and just to because
i see where you're going here just to
re-emphasize one thing we are expanding
our railways i'm opening lines which
were cut in the 60s and 70s under the
beaching cuts we're building new
railways in the you know the northern
powerhouse rail hs2 and elsewhere so
we're expanding our railways it's not a
question of making them smaller uh what
i'm more interested in is how to run
them properly rather than keeping
positions exactly as they were
throughout history which is not working
for our railway
okay uh now you haven't met with the rmt
since the 13th of may
they want to meet with you why won't you
meet with them
because the negotiations need to take
place with the employers those are the
people who have the power to
settle this
mick lynch and the rmt know this it's a
stunt that at the 11th hour they're
suddenly saying they want to meet up in
fact only last month the unions were
saying they would not negotiate with the
government they would refuse to meet as
mick lynch put it with the tory
government his words as i say they
balloted for this action in april before
the pay offer was even on the table
under false pretences telling their
members that they weren't going to get a
pay rise without it which was totally
untrue and yesterday they thought it was
more important to attend a tuc rally
than carry on talking i think it tells
you everything that you need to know
about this i won't undermine these talks
uh by getting in between the employer
and the employees the unions
okay you say that you don't want to
undermine the talks it's not for the
government to get involved but you know
there are claims that actually the train
offering operating companies can't
negotiate fully
because at the minute because of the
emergency
measures agreements agree during covid
the government effectively bankrolls the
railways so you set the kind of
financial framework the caps if you like
the ceilings
under which these negotiations can take
place with that in mind should the
government not be in the talks uh if you
are the one setting the ceilings
no
it's true to say that the taxpayer is
bankrolling the the railway so that's
absolutely true to say um but the
train operating companies through
something called the rail delivery group
and network rail they have the
authorities to uh carry out the
negotiations you can't carry out them
out if the if the rmt union has left the
table to go to a rally but is it right
that the government has set the pay
ceilings
of course there's a this is no secret
there's a there's a national um pay
approach taken by the chancellor across
the uh public sector i've said that if
we can get the modernization that this
railway desperately needs and get rid of
these working practices that for example
mean that if somebody's taking a break a
20-minute break and the manager happens
to walk past and say hi bob then the
person taking the break can restart the
20 minutes from scratch because they
were interrupted
just to come so if the government is
setting the pay ceilings
it's fair that you should be involved in
the negotiations isn't it if you know
the rmt are concerned about the pace
if they're workers
no
and and the trade unions know that only
the employer and the trade union can
settle this um to explain uh these talks
have been ongoing for a long time there
are about 20 different areas of detailed
uh and i'd say in some cases very
productive work going on that
modernization uh in in such levels of
detail that only an employer could
possibly have those negotiations i will
not cut across that i will not undermine
the employer's work i'm afraid this is a
stunt at the 11th hour by the union
whilst they're off holding a rally
suddenly coming forward and saying uh we
need to negotiate with the government
now even though as i said just last
month they were telling me they wouldn't
be seen dead negotiating with the with
the government okay the correct thing to
happen um it's a point you've already
made mr chaps um next week obviously as
could be just the start of the strike so
the rmt is saying that you know they'll
be looking at potentially
more action throughout the summer as
well
if these strikes are ongoing if they
could last for days what would the
consequences be i mean we've talked
about you know the lights potentially
going out is that a possibility
no i don't think we'll see that and uh
even whilst these strikes are ongoing
we'll see uh freight being moved around
perhaps fifty percent of the normal
levels um but i would say this you know
i hear the the leadership of this quite
militant unions nostalgic for the old
type of union power they had they don't
seem to realize the world has changed
we've been through coronavirus traveling
by train was a necessity for millions of
people before
now it's optional for a lot of those
passengers who we've desperately been
trying to get back onto the railway and
things have changed people can more
often work from home the people i'm
really upset for people actually like my
daughter who need to get to their a
levels next week and students pupils
people trying to get to hospitals those
are the people who are going to suffer
actually key workers often lower paid
workers who can't do their work from
home that's who the rmt is damaging and
it's completely unacceptable
earlier this week you told railway
workers that you risk striking
yourselves out of a job um
it sounds a bit like a threat
no it's a statement of reality right the
the railways have been on this 16
billion pound life support the
equivalent roughly of the entire police
budget in the country for the year
that's how much money we put in 600
pounds per household
of course it's a reality that if we
can't get these railways modernized if
we can't get uh the kind of efficiency
that will mean that they can work on
behalf of the traveling um public then
of course it's jeopardizing the future
of the railway itself i think it's a
huge act of self-harm to go on strike at
the moment i don't believe workers are
anywhere near as militant as their
unions who are leading them up a garden
path uh they're gunning for the strike
it's completely unnecessary there's a
sensible pay deal there's a sensible i
think modernization of the railway which
would enable much more flexibility and
much more automation and much safer
railway but the unions need to
understand the world has changed and
people don't need to necessarily travel
as they did in the past which is um
unfortunate
we want people back at work as the
government's been
saying we think it's a better
environment but people many people will
be able to function from home and the
unions don't seem to realize that people
don't need the products in quite the
same way as they once did now the
government is looking at changing some
legislation around strikes so allowing
companies to cover striking workers with
agency staff also potentially increasing
the maximum damages that businesses can
claim for illegal strikes up to a
million pounds is that correct and how
quickly could it be brought in yeah
that's correct um minimum service levels
as well which was in our manifesto which
would mean that certain levels of
service would need to be maintained even
on a strike day what you described as
agency workers coming in is slightly
incorrect what we're actually talking
about is for example if you had somebody
in an operations room at the moment they
can be looking at one screen they won't
move around to another screen because uh
the union rules forbid it as it happens
unless you make them a payment at which
point they say it's safe and they can do
it
what we're talking about is requiring
that kind of flexibility so it's more
transferable skills uh than it is agency
work um in this case
and a range of other things as i say
much of which really doesn't need to
happen if we could just get to a
sensible settlement here but i'm afraid
they are gunning for this um strike as
we've seen by them walking out of the
talks yesterday to attend a rally
uh unfortunately i think therefore we
need to protect the traveling public
um i want to talk to you a bit about
what's happening at the airports as well
uh anyone who has been on holiday or
travelled recently will have seen
firsthand the chaos that is going on
um gatwick has said it's going to reduce
capacity in the summer which means more
cancelled flights are you concerned that
other
airports could do the same thing and how
long could we see this going on for
well we've certainly seen a difficult
bounce back you'll recall both
at easter but also at the whitson uh
holidays those those scenes uh we've
said to the aviation sector that can't
carry on uh and we have a working group
set up with them which is meeting all
the time working very closely with the
aviation um sector we have a series of
different uh things that we're going to
be putting in place and asking them to
do one of which was to ask them to
review their schedules now not on the
day of the flight or the day before
where they destroy somebody's holiday
but in advance and actually i i welcome
uh what gatwick have done to sensibly
look at the schedule and see whether it
could actually be fulfilled
and give people notice now rather than
in six weeks time five weeks time uh
which is what they've done i think
that's smart we'll be coming forward
with some further um ideas to help
alleviate pressure fundamentally of
course it's down to the industry they
need to make sure they employ people get
them in the right places this reminds me
a lot of the problem that we had with a
shortage of lorry uh drivers which we
fixed through 33 different measures uh
that the government and the sector
brought together uh brought forward
together and i'd like to do the same in
the aviation sector
well i'll just give you to give you one
example something we already did which
was make it easier and faster to employ
people getting through the security
referencing system um so we made a
change in the law there and some
technical changes to make it easier to
do that
and and there are more measures along
those types of lines from a government
point of view
and then from an industry point of view
things like them looking at their
schedule as they've done is very helpful
but we'll be saying more about this
actually in the coming week uh i'll say
more about this um but we're we're
watching it like a hawk working very
closely with the aviation sector they
had a stop start two years i understand
how they've got to this position what we
need to do is fix it for uh holiday
makers and people who want to travel by
air and this summer
it feels um just look at the jobs market
a bit more widely um it feels like we're
in a strange situation where it's almost
as if the jobs market is a bit too hot
and we've got 1.3 million vacancies in
the labour market the issue of course is
getting people to fill the jobs and paul
scully uh the minister told sky news
this week that the answer could be
trying to get people to be a bit more
productive so if they're part-time
seeing if they want to work more hours
he was talking about people who've
recalibrated what they want to do when
on furlough
do you agree with him
what i would say actually is i i think
the solution in aviation as in the rest
of the economy is actually not
dissimilar to the way that we've solved
uh or on our way to solving i should
probably say the hgv lorry crisis which
was causing so many problems you
remember even including with tankers at
the
petrol pumps uh and we did that by
looking at the entire market for those
employees paying a little bit more
actually often that was at the at the
very heart of it making sure people were
attracted to the industry just this week
i've launched something called
generation logistics so i think those
are the types of things which help to
resolve this problem as what you
described is an incredibly tight jobs
market i did listen to your introduction
actually and you're saying oh it's a bit
like the 70s well the big difference is
unemployment was a big problem uh
certainly later in the 70s uh what we've
got now is an economy which is
unfortunately very very high levels of
employment and very low unemployment so
i do think continuously skilling people
up more automation
things like that help with productivity
but also just making sure that each
sector is attractive enough to go into
and if you look at baggage handlers for
example i don't think they've had the
best deals and the best packages in the
past i think we've got to make those
jobs uh worthwhile well paid
and
uncomfortable jobs to do a bit more
attractive uh to encourage people to do
them understood um just finally
during boris johnson's leadership
campaign
you were famously the man with the
spreadsheet you predicted to the number
the number of uh conservative mps who
get it back at boris johnson's
leadership campaign
during the recent confidence vote when
148 mps uh voted against boris johnson
did number 10 call on your services
again
but i did make a prediction but i have
to say actually it's a it's a
statistical prediction so in fact
that doesn't tell you was it was it
correct did you get all the money again
i did um but but but you did get it on
the network
sorry you so you correctly predicted 148
mps again
um
one out of five but uh but but uh i
should point out it's not as useful as
it sounds it's not as good as it sounds
it's a statistical prediction rather
than a individuals who voted
specifically in one way uh or the others
i do not want to over uh play the uh the
advantage of this because most whips
want to know who was involved whereas my
outsider looking in uh version of it was
look this is the picture as as i see it
on the subject itself getting getting
getting just one out you did much better
than number 10 who was seemingly
predicting you know far less uh mps were
going to rebel than they did did you
tell boris johnson about your prediction
did you warn him
well well look i'm not going to get into
sort of details of the conversation what
i was going to say though is um speaking
to even some of those who didn't support
the prime minister a couple of weeks ago
which i've done some of the some of the
the names which would be most
recognizable with people who've been
critical everyone now is in the mood of
let's give the prime minister the
opportunity the space the time to uh
make sure that he can carry on with some
of the uh work that he's doing we just
saw him in kiev a couple of days ago
and as president zielinski um says where
britain goes other follow others follow
with regard to
the war in ukraine i think he's showing
great international leadership there
he's going to help us get through these
challenges that we're facing at home
including um things like um cost of
living and some of the things we've been
doing on the railways prior to the
strikes like making sure that we we have
offers available for people to buy to
attract people back to the railways
through the through the sale and and
many many other things high employment
levels these are the things which really
matter to people so you know i just
think uh i i agree with some with some
of those who who didn't support the
prime minister we need to give uh the
opportunity uh for this government to do
what it was elected to do
notwithstanding that it had two years of
a huge uh health crisis to deal with as
well and looking back on that the prime
minister got us the injections first the
jabs first he got us out of lockdown
first in the world and those things are
things that this prime minister achieve
above anybody else
understood we are out of time at grant
chaps uh thank you very much for being
on the program this morning
thank you thanks so much